turns out that when people are wealthier
and have more choices that they choose
to do all this stuff they choose to
protect biodiversity they choose to make
Parks they choose to uh make room for
Stuff Beyond kind of straight up
conventional profitable activity um and
conversely that slightly slowing down I
mean you know this is what the sort of
reasonable position right it's like hey
you know GDP ain't everything like we
could just we could just let it go you
know just maybe half a percent we could
just slow it down a little um and we
could have all these other things in
exchange I think first of all that
exchange is often a false one and second
even slowing down growth a little has
massive massive consequences in the long
term this is just the kind of compound
interest theory of things um that a
little less growth now is is
unconscionably less for future
Generations